[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up guys Michael here to talk
about
Jordan Peterson well there is much that
could be said about this increasingly
teary-eyed man I have one purpose and
one purpose only to check out some of
Peterson's lectures where he talks about
post-modern philosophy in particular I
want to see if I can figure out why he
thinks that post-modern philosophy as
embodied by French philosophers like
Jacques deridan Michelle Foucault is one
of the most imminent threats to
contemporary human culture sounds scary
I know but before we get into it a few
notes to help guide us on our journey
and if you're really anti you know just
give forward a minute and I'll start
watching Clips first I'm only going to
watch Clips where Peterson is talking
about philosophy and philosophers this
guy says a lot of stuff and lots of
people on YouTube have made videos
saying stuff about the stuff he says so
check those out if you want but today
I'm staying in my Lane second he talks a
lot about post-modernism which is a
super broad category used to describe
everything from architecture to visual
art to beer but thankfully he makes it
clear that he's referring to a certain
strand of post-war French philosophy
usually referred to as
post-structuralism or deconstruction
embodied in the work of Michelle
Foucault and Jacques Daria and while
Peterson makes them sound like active
threats to the safety of your family
fouca has been dead since 1984. um Daria
went to be with baby Jesus in 2004. um
so they're not going to get you now I'll
talk about it more once we get going but
the important thing to know is that both
deridan Foucault took a critical
approach to the history of Western
philosophy and for Foucault Western
Civilization more generally and to
different extents both were interested
in looking at the way in which platonic
idealism I.E the philosophy of Plato and
Christian metaphysics led to a
hierarchical tendency in philosophy
which basically means one in which truth
is a vertical Journey from the stuff we
see in front of us to the actual truth
that exists at some higher plane whether
it's a realm of perfect forms for Plato
or you know for Christian theology God's
house of great ideas and building on
this they were both interested in how
idealist and Christian logic were used
to make absolute claims on things like
truth and Power by both thinkers and
political actors third as we'll see
Peterson describes lots of very
dangerous ideas and cultural Trends to
the work of these philosophers and
spoiler alert but I think at best he's
just often at worst he seems to have
genuinely not read these guys so you
might be asking why even spend your time
on this well for one people listen to
Peterson and it's important that folks
know when he's wrong about Big Ideas and
more importantly I think it's important
to ask why would he vilify a couple of
dead French philosophers now after
watching 20 or so hours of his lectures
on the topic I'm honestly not totally
sure and you know I'm hesitant to
speculate about his inner intentions but
his anger towards these philosophers and
their ideas seem to come from him
feeling as if they are calling his
subject identity and position into
question put a little differently it
seems like the work of Foucault and
derida when properly understood might
call some of Peterson's own assumptions
about truth culture and Society into
question which is you know the point of
philosophy finally Peterson jumps around
a lot in his lectures so it's hard to
not cover lots of ground when trying to
get to the bottom of these critiques he
has of philosophy so if there's anything
that doesn't quite make sense or if you
guys have more questions or comments
please drop them them in the comments
right here and I'll try my best to get
back to you so let's get into it in this
philosopher reacts to Jordan Peterson on
post-modernism but before we get into it
I want to tell you about this video
sponsor fabulous the number one
self-care app to help you build better
habits and achieve your goals if you
have difficulty sticking to new routines
and I know that I do or if you'd like to
improve your happiness on a daily basis
which I do as well fabulous can be an
excellent solution it's a digital coach
that uses Behavioral Science to help you
create and stick to fresh new habits
with fabulous you can adopt a
personalized daily routine that can help
you tackle goals of any size if you want
to decrease stress increase productivity
or even drink more water every day
fabulous can help the app helps you
create rituals throughout the day
starting from the moment you wake up
these small steps help you ease into new
habits and can lead to long lasting
changes fabulous offers two programs to
choose from dedicated programs or habit
tracking with the dedicated programs
you're immersed in a multi-week journey
of guided self-discovery fabulous will
send you inspiring and motivational
letters and at the end of each one
you'll choose a positive action for that
week these new positive actions are
added to your daily routine and the app
sends friendly reminders to help you
stick to them if you opt for the Habit
tracking approach you can go at your own
pace as you complete bite-sized tasks
and get gentle encouragement throughout
the day you can choose from 100 tasks
within the app or add your own and with
the fabulous premium account you can
track an unlimited number of habits and
access all the programs and exercises
the app has to offer like coaching
sessions and support circles join the
community of more than 30 million users
around the world and start building your
ideal daily routine the first 100 people
who click on the link in the description
will get 25 percent off their fabulous
subscription so check it out today and
now back to the show okay here's a video
where Peterson talks about
post-modernism and cultural Marxism from
what looks like a very lovely cabin by
the way so let's let's start that
there's a postmodern philosophy
which we'll talk about a bit that really
came into its Vogue in the 1970s after
Classic Marxism especially of the
economic type had been so thoroughly
discredited that no one but an absolute
reprobate could could uh could support
it publicly anymore even the French
intellectuals had to admit that
communism was a bad deal by the by the
end of the 1960s okay so that right
there it's worth noting when he says
that anyone who could support Marxism
was a reprobate and the French
intellectuals didn't I mean that's just
historically wrong so um Louis altaze
was a super influential professor in
Paris um was around at the time of
someone like Jacques derida and was a
Marxist wrote a lot of books on Marx and
a lot of his students people like ETI
and balibar Jacques Ron Sierra Alon baju
all who are still working
um are all to very success Marxist
philosophers who were all studying
teaching writing speaking in France in
Paris in the 60s and 70s
um none of whom were shy about their
engagement with the Marxist tradition so
that's just kind of not true
even the French intellectuals like
Sartre Jean-Paul Sartre the famous
philosopher had to admit by the end of
the 1960s that the the stalinist
Communist maoist experiment and all of
its variants not just those particular
dictators but all of its variants was an
absolute catastrophic failure
okay so he says something about sart
here which is both true and not true
um sart absolutely was critical of some
of the violent political catastrophes
that took place under the name of
Communism in Europe at the same time
this did not lead to a disavow of
Marxism you know starting with sart's
work search for a method he said a huge
part of his project was trying to find a
sort of philosophical synthesis and
existentialism and Marxism he does that
um up through his work the critique of
dialectical reason and it remains an
interest of his so I think that Peterson
right here is confusing you know
philosophers being critical of existing
political events with those philosophers
then disavowing the writings of Karl
Marx which are two different things okay
um jumping had a little bit Peterson is
still talking about his sort of like
intellectual history of what
post-modernism is they started to pit
the oppressor the oppressed against the
oppressor and that opened up the avenue
to identifying any number of groups as
oppressed and oppressor and to continue
the same narrative under a different
name it was no longer specifically about
economics it was about power and
everything to the postmodernist is about
power and that's actually why they're so
dangerous because if you're
engaged in a discussion with someone who
believes in nothing but Power
all they are motivated to do is to
accrue all the power to them because
what else is there okay so he says that
everything for the most modernist is
about power and that they want to
acquire power
well if we think about people like
Jacques derida and Michelle Foucault the
only two names that Peterson will use
when saying who the postmodern
philosophers are the acquisition of
power was not a concern for them
um to various extents the analysis of
the way that power functions and has
functioned in society was important for
them but deridan particular
I mean he talks about power but his his
primary method deconstruction is not a
method of gaining power if anything it's
a method of undermining claims to
consistent knowledge or problematizing
sort of trends of acquiring knowledge in
Western philosophy if you look at
Foucault's work when he's doing these
genealogical histories
he's not trying to figure out how to get
power he's looking at how power has been
used and abused and modified throughout
history so it's kind of like saying that
if I write a book about the history of
sharks that I would like to be a shark
myself right I could write about sharks
and not want to be a shark or you know
if I write Gilmore Girls fan fiction I
wish that I was actress Alexis Bledel no
I'm just writing Gilmore Girls fan
fiction I don't want to be a Gilmore
Girl basically that there's no
discussion there's no Meeting of Minds
and consensus there's power
and so since the 1970s under the guise
of post-modernism we've seen the rapid
expansion of identity politics
throughout the universities it's came
it's come to dominate all of the
humanities which are which are dead as
far as I can tell and a huge proportion
of the social scientists sciences and
we've been publicly funding extremely
radical post-modern leftist thinkers who
are hell-bent on demolishing the
fundamental substructure of Western
civilization and that's no that's no
paranoid delusion that's that's that's
their self-admitted goal yeah I don't
know maybe it's different in Canada but
in my experiences of being a Humanities
academic post-modernism it's kind of out
of fashion by the time I even started
grad school but maybe it came back
around like how kids are wearing baggy
pants again and I've identified not only
me obviously but one of the main players
in this entire drama is a French
philosopher named Jacques derrada who
was who I think most transiently
formulated the anti-western philosophy
that is being pursued so assiduously by
the radical
so this is this one's hard because
I don't know what it means first of all
to say that darita
um had this trenchant formation of an
anti-western philosophy now darita was
critical of elements of Western Society
the same way that any philosopher would
be because
a part of doing philosophy is looking
back historically on the tradition and
critically modifying previous
assumptions so when Descartes uh he of
of I think therefore I am Fame
develops this form of rationalism part
of that involves criticizing previous
assumptions about Western subjectivity
some of those which go back to Plato or
Aristotle now that doesn't make
Descartes you know this trenchant
violent
um you know enemy of Western philosophy
it simply means that he's engaging with
that tradition right he's
re-articulating classical philosophical
questions in his own
um era which is a big part of what
philosophy does and derida's Method
called deconstruction aims for a type of
internal critique he's looking for sort
of critique that is internal to text
themselves
but he's not someone who's just pointing
his finger at Western society and saying
bad and I also don't think the degree to
which it's already infiltrated our
culture can be overstated
I mean the the people who hold this
Doctrine this radical post-modern
communitarian doctrine that that makes
racial Identity or sexual identity or
gender identity or some kind of group
identity Paramount they've got control
over most
low to mid-level bureaucratic structures
and and many governments as well but but
even in the United States where you know
a lot of the governmental institutions
have swung back to the Republican side
the postmodernist types have infiltrated
bureaucratic organizations at the mid to
upper level okay this seems pretty
Bonkers to me because the argument would
be that bureaucracies and governments in
our world are being controlled by people
who are followers of philosophers like
terira and Foucault and while that might
be cool if it were the case I don't see
a lot of evidence of that but if you do
know who these deconstructionist and
fucodians are that are running the
government please shout them out in the
comments if you're dealing with with
systemic problems of poverty for example
or trying to determine how to how to
produce more opportunity for everyone to
benefit from everyone's abilities you
have to use a hell of a lot more than
compassion to get there and to so to
think of of community in the positive
sense as being driven by nothing but
empathy which is really one of the
central arguments of the of the
post-modern types at least that's what's
driving some of their argumentation is
it's an absurd proposition
so it's not so much that they confuse
the two things is that they fail to
differentiate the concepts to begin with
it it's very very difficult to build
functional structures that help people
thrive individually and socially over
long periods of time okay so this idea
that
post-modern philosophers are driven by
empathy that it's absurd to be driven by
empathy first thing you don't see a lot
of discussion of empathy again in people
like deridan Foucault what I do think is
interesting is Daria has this notion of
unconditional hospitality and that
doesn't just mean like unlimited
breadsticks or something for him it
means that we let others in no matter
what we don't exclude everyone is a
friend and not enemy even when that
becomes dangerous because of course
unconditional hospitality is dangerous
imagine if you just like left your door
open at all times of day and said come
on in that would be dangerous but this
is a way of thinking about what real
Justice and real democracy looks like so
you could say that maybe that's driven
by a type of empathy I I would struggle
to see why that empathy is bad but of
course what derida is doing is thinking
through kind of the problem or the
Paradox of Justice the Paradox of
unconditional hospitality and and
getting us to think about that
impossibility and what that means so
but maybe empathy is bad I don't know
maybe maybe I'm not gonna be empathetic
anymore I think I think no I think
that's what I'm gonna do now I'm no
longer going to be empathetic dareda
described wet the West as male dominated
which I think is a is a is something to
take serious issue with as as a blatant
claim it's not differentiated enough or
sophisticated enough and he also said it
was logos Centric and that partly means
logic but there's a deeper meaning to
logos because logos is also the second
person of the Christian Trinity and Dara
knew that perfectly well okay so here
Peterson's playing a bit fast and loose
when he is talking about derida thinking
that society's male dominated he's
referring to his critique of foul
logocentrism and he brings up the logo
centrism here logocentrism is a critique
of a hierarchy of knowledge like what we
get in Plato where ideas matter more
than like representations of those ideas
or images we see of them now the fallow
centers in part this comes or starts
from Freud Freud thought that the
literal biological penis played a role
in the development of the unconscious
now Jacques Lacon a French
psychoanalytic theorist a contemporary
of daradas in Paris critiqued Freud's
literalization of the phallus and
instead he talked about the phallus as a
signifier not an actual biological penis
right so the phallus and this is
according to Adrian Johnston's reading
of lacan
um has a structural function it doesn't
talk about the literal penis and it's
the structural function whatever a child
hypothesizes the paternal figure
possesses making in the focus of the
maternal figures desire okay so when
we're talking about phallic desire it's
a desire for power a desire to be the
big other a desire to be like God so
what is phallogocentrism then well it's
a critique of the dominance of a
hierarchical form of knowledge in
Western philosophy and it's a critique
of the idea or the the structure of
phallic desire in Western society which
doesn't mean desire for penises it means
a desire for a certain type of
hierarchical
um power power of the big other the
power of God whatever it might be
um so I think that's where Peterson
misunderstands what's happening and what
leads him to then say that Daria simply
says like the West is male dominated but
also I don't know Google like how many
presidents are men or or how many
leaders of large corporations are men
like I mean like obviously that's not
what dared I was talking about but it's
like pretty true that most political
leaders and Business Leaders are are men
so there you go the the logo Centric
idea is
his criticism of the idea of the
logocentric society is a deep criticism
of the idea that the individual as a
speaking Force as a communicative force
is the appropriate
highest value upon which a culture
should be built he took that apart and
criticized it and and so that's that's a
deeper criticism I would say even in
Marx's criticism which was mostly about
unequal power relationships darede went
deeper than that and the the
post-modernists that occupy the
universities are anti-individual right
down to the right down to the Bedrock
and so that's partly why they push
collectivism to such a degree they don't
give a damn who you are they care what
your group identity is and that's that
okay so what Peterson is talking about
here is dairy dog's critique of
logocentrism now he seems to think it's
a critique of the speaking individual
being but again it's not really a social
critique it's a philosophical critique
and the idea again is that logocentrism
is a critique of hierarchical ways of
thinking about knowledge largely going
back to Plato So Daryl's not saying
logic doesn't exist he's not saying that
truth doesn't exist he's saying that the
idea that language is the primary way
that we access direct truth and in
particular that there is this absolute
truth that we can access in this like
mathematical way
um is untrue right and we see that in
Plato and Descartes and others okay so
there's so much going on in this video
um I guess you can watch the whole thing
yourself if you want I wouldn't really
recommend it but I want to look at one
last thing he says about post-modernism
and philosophy and books here's how you
interpret a book if you're a
post-modernist like a fiction book you
don't read the book and try to
understand what utility might be
extracted out of it to guide you in your
life
that's the old system the new system is
you read the book and you analyze it in
terms of whose
societal position of power it justifies
so you look for who the supremacist is
in the text could be it could be the
author it could be the characters it
doesn't matter you read the text as if
all it does is reflect
on the current corrupt power structure
that obtains in current society and
that's that's that's the beginnings of
literary criticism under the social
justice regime okay this is a weird one
um at least in terms of philosophy I
think it's very weird to say that the
point of reading a text philosophically
is the extraction of utility to see how
it can guide your life of course there's
works of moral philosophy that do just
that but when he says that
post-modernists analyze books in terms
of whose societal position of power
justifies or whatever it's not really it
so deridot did think that critique was
internal to the text that it's all in
the text itself but what deconstruction
is is a method of approaching a text to
see how it self deconstructs to see
where that sort of Auto deconstruction
is operating which means that when I
approach a text I'm reading it against
itself what I'm not doing is taking an
external intellectual framework and
laying it over the text and using that
to analyze which seems to be what
Peterson is saying here instead I'm
analyzing the text on its own terms but
kind of looking for those spaces those
inconsistencies those paradoxes in the
text itself it's a very difficult way of
approaching text and I would never say
it's not but what Peterson is saying
here is super reductive to um diridian
deconstruction and how it's applied to
literary Theory okay um I want to look a
little bit at this lecture that Peterson
gave called identity politics and the
Marxist lie of white privilege and again
I think to get ready for this video I
watched 30 or 40 hours of Peterson and
it's been hard to narrow it down so I
want to jump around here a little bit
and really look at some of the stuff he
says about post-modernism and postmodern
philosophy again just a reminder the
only names that I have seen him use when
he talks about who the postmodern
philosophers are are Jacques darita and
Michelle Foucault so if you hear me
talking about them it's because he did
it first and so the world they Envision
as far as I can tell is something like a
it's a sociologically hobbsian nightmare
so Hobbes thought of the philosopher
Thomas Hobbs thought of the natural
state of human beings as every
individual in some sense at the throat
of every other individual
so that the basic state of man mankind
unlike the russoian state of say virgin
innocence and and the Primitive Garden
of paradise was uh an all-out war of
everyone against everyone else and that
that required the imposition of the
social order to keep peace essentially
so it's a it's a very dark view of of
humankind Russo on the other hand would
think of people as intrinsically good in
the social order as intrinsically
tyrannical
you can actually think about Hobbs and
Rousseau in some sense of as as as
opposites that need to be paired
together in order to get a relatively
comprehensive view of human nature well
the postmodern view is like the Hobson
view in some sense except you want to
replace the individual with with with
pyramids of of
social organizations so hierarchies of
social organization that are based on
group identity
and that the landscape in which those
pyramids exist is one of unbroken enmity
and inability to communicate so it's a
very dark view as far as I'm concerned
and I think it's fundamentally wrong
okay so the claim here is that
post-modern philosophers want to replace
the category of the individual and we'll
start there just by saying
no they want to criticize the structure
of individual subjectivity in Western
philosophy and rethink how it interacts
with systems of power and then replace
it with social hierarchies founded on
identities look at the head Joker at the
top of the postmodern hierarchy as
dareda Foucault is often mentioned as
are a number of other people
um
here's some other attributes of
post-modern thinking uh
there's a recognition of the existence
of hierarchy that's for sure
and there's an echo of that idea
the recognition of hierarchy and the
term patriarchy because of course
patriarchy is a recognition of hierarchy
now it's a very particular kind of
recognition but the postmodernists also
tend to Define
hierarchy as a consequence of power
differential but the notion of social
hierarchies is not primary for deridar
Foucault in any prescriptive sense now
dareda is interested in democracy and
it's impossibility but democracy
nonetheless and Foucault isn't really
interested in top-down hierarchical
power he's interested in the way in
which power functions at the term of
networks right so when Foucault does
analysis of how power Works in society
um you know it's a it's a microphysics
of power he wants to look at the way
power is structured in the every day so
for Foucault it's more about a bottom-up
analysis and not a top-down analysis to
see how subjects are constituted by
these networks of power again it's not
saying that the individual subject
doesn't exist but that they are
constituted by networks of power but in
neither case do we see dareda or foucos
saying we need to get rid of individuals
and replace them with hierarchical
networks of power founded on identities
it's just not in the text the hierarchy
is in functioning Western democracies
are fundamentally predicated on Power
and tyranny and then you know I can use
a biological example too which would
Place me outside of the postmodern realm
of argument because the post-modernists
don't believe in biology but but they
act like they do because they all die so
okay
um this is a real wild claim right I
don't know what it means to say that
they don't believe that biology exists
here's what I know I'll give you some
facts
daried I was interested enough to do an
entire seminar
um on biology it was called The V
L'Amour he interacted with molecular
biology and genetics via the work of a
biologist named Francois Jacob so he
believed in biology enough to dedicate a
seminar to it Foucault
um has this notion of biopower we talked
about it in the boys video recently
which presupposes that biology exists
and not only does it exist but Co thinks
it's an utterly important category when
we think about modern society so for
Foucault biopower describes the
regulation and control of human life and
populations he called it the set of
mechanisms through which the basic
biological features of the human species
became the odd object of a political
strategy of a general strategy of power
or in other words I was starting from
the 18th Century Modern Western
societies took on board the fundamental
biological fact that human beings are a
species so um again it was a silly
comment for him to make but it seems
irresponsible to me
if you're going to level critiques
against an intellectual tradition and
then if you were going to identify two
people as your primary targets and a
critique of a tradition to not have a
cursory knowledge of their work is very
frustrating and it makes it really hard
to really interact with this other than
just saying like no you're wrong
um because he's saying things that are
so out of pocket uh but let's let's see
what else he says so you know so much
for the idea that power is the only game
in town then you got to ask the question
is well this is actually a post-modern
question so you know one of the things
dareda said the the main post-modern
Joker is that by categorizing
you you you privilege one concept and
you pre you force other Concepts out to
the margins and so he believed that when
you constructed a hierarchy of power
that the hierarchy of power privileged
certain people and marginalized others
okay I find this really confusing
because Peterson implies that
hierarchies don't fundamentally
privilege some things over other things
um one definition of hierarchy is an
arrangement of items objects names
values categories that are represented
as being above below or at the same
level as one another so like in terms of
things being above or below I don't see
how that doesn't involve privileging
like if I say
um that as a fruit a blueberry is above
an apple I'm hierarchically I'm
hierarchically privileging a blueberry
over an apple I do think that too apples
are I don't like apples they're really
Mealy
and every time I try to like once a year
I'm like I'm gonna eat an apple again
and it's so mealy
um but the hierarchies that Dairy dog
talks about again refer back to that
critique of logocentrism
um and the idea that speech is
hierarchically opposed to writing that
presence is hierarchically opposed a
representation and again this is more to
do with the critique of Plato's idealism
and its Legacy and philosophy
than it is with Dario critiquing some
contemporary social hierarchy
um and I think that that confusion is at
play here um and of course the
implication for Peterson is that deridan
wants to push others out that
marginalization is good
but Dairy dog is all about democracy
um we talked about this before he's all
about unconditional Hospitality now he
does think democracy is paradoxically
tied up with Sovereign power I mean that
there is a paradox implied in how
democracy functions
but this democracy to come that he
speaks of is still something that should
push us towards the future and I think
that it's fair to say deridas
fundamentally Democratic thinker would
love to break it down more but it's
complicated so um go read some dare it
off you want it's it can be fun it's
frustrating but it's fun you have to ask
why it is that you would if you were a
post-modernist
yourself why it is that you would
privilege the idea of power above all
else it's exactly what is it that you're
pushing to the margin
and so that's something that we're going
to talk about now here's one thing you
might push to the margin let's say that
you believe that hierarchies are a
consequence of power
well then you push confidence to the
margin and then applying the post-modern
modernist logic you might say well the
reason you're privileging power is so
that you can produce so that you could
push confidence to the margin okay so
when he says again that Daria wants
power above all else it wants to push
people to the margins I don't see how
that works with dairydas categories of
unconditional hospitality and radical
friendship um this is a quote this is
from darede's book of hospitality he
says absolute Hospitality requires that
I open up my home and then I give not
only to The Foreigner but to the
absolute unknown Anonymous other
so that's what Dairy dog says okay
um that's enough Jordan Peterson for one
day so thank you so much for sticking
with me through that and again if you
have any questions or want further
explanation of anything we got into
please drop those in the comments below
I mean it drop them I'll try to respond
to them okay so what did we learn today
well I think at least two things one is
that both Jacques Dario and Michelle
Foucault wanted to push philosophy
Beyond a traditional platonist or
metaphysical Paradigm in a search for
more just and Democratic forms of
thought and two whatever Peterson thinks
post-modernism is he's absolutely not
talking about deridan Foucault and their
influence or at least that's what he
thinks he's doing
instead he seems to be using
post-modernism as a straw man that gives
him a type of Lefty intellectual
Boogeyman to fight against and while it
might seem easy to Simply dismiss this
as a cynical and willful misreading of a
couple of philosophers the reality might
be more harmful because like it or not
Jordan Peterson is a wildly influential
public intellectual who many people and
especially young dudes on the internet
take as an authority figure on subjects
like psychology ethics and philosophy
and when public intellectuals whose job
it is to convey complicated ideas and
understandable and relatable terms abuse
the trust the public puts in them the
effects can be bad like really bad so
this stuff matters but what do you all
think like I said before let us know in
the comments and as always if there's
any other thinker or movie or TV show
you think warrants a philosophical
reaction please let us know a huge
thanks to all our patrons for your
support and do check out our patreon
page if you haven't in a while we have
some great stuff going on there and the
support means a lot to us
um like this video if you liked it or if
you just want to you know support the
work I did and watching all that Jordan
Peterson mean a lot and thanks as always
for watching it means so much to us I'll
catch you later
[Music]
all right
[Music]